we not only see she as a bride but she's  eight months pregnant interior wedding  chapel day overhead shot we hear step  step to the man we haven't seen yet  enters the shop right next to the Fallen  Rock The Bride speaks for the first time  in the picture she looks up at the man  standing over her and says bill it's  your baby  a beat after she says the word baby we  hear a bang and the bride receives a  bullet on the side of her head cut to  black screen before film I quit  insurance  I laid in a coma for five years we  dissolved to a matching close-up of the  young woman the young woman's behind the  wheel of a big car white wedding gown on  she's talking into the camera I've  killed 18 men in the last week didn't  feel a thing and to him is where I'm  driving because there's no one left  worth killing except him and when I get  to where I'm going I'm gonna kill Bill  the music then the you know title song  begins